un combattant taliban montent la garde
devant la carcasse d'une voiture
détruite c'est depuis ce véhicule que
des roquettes visant ce lundi matin
l'aéroport de kaboul aurait été tiré
j'étais à l'intérieur de la maison avec
mes enfants et d'autres membres de la
famille soudain il ya eu des explosions
nous avons sauté dans l'enceinte de la
maison et nous nous sommes allongées sur
le sol une nouvelle attaque en direction
de l'aéroport
confirmée par washington à la veille du
départ prévu de l'armée américaine
dont les dernières évacuations se
déroule dans un climat particulièrement
tendu
quelques heures plus tôt l'armée
américaine réalise une frappe aérienne
contre un véhicule chargé d'explosifs se
dirigeant vers l'aéroport de la capitale
afghane une action contre le groupe etat
islamique en plein milieu d'habitations
qui aurait fait plusieurs victimes
civiles
nous sommes au courant que des victimes
civiles ont été annoncées à la suite de
notre frappe sur un véhicule à kaboul
nous sommes toujours en train d'évaluer
les résultats de cette frappe qui nous
le savons en rien la 6me nantes de
l'oica contre l'aéroport
ce qui s'est passé n'est pas clair et
nous continuons d'enquêter c'est la
seconde opération américaines depuis
l'attentât de l'aéroport de kaboul
samedi une frappe de drone dans l'est de
l'afghanistan a tué deux membres de haut
niveau de la branche afghane du groupe
etat islamique et blessé un troisième d
action condamnée par les talibans à
présent que les américains quittent
notre pays ils doivent respecter notre
indépendance
parce que c'est notre pays nous qui
détenons le pouvoir s'il ya une menace
nous devons être au courant afin d'y
faire face d'enquêté ou si nécessaire de
mener des opérations contre elle les
américains ne peuvent rien faire de leur
côté nous les condamnons ne peuvent pas
mener de telles opérations
ils doivent cesser ils n'ont aucun droit
de faire de telles opérations en
afghanistan
notre indépendance doit être respectée
main sur le coeur le président américain
a accueilli ce dimanche les dépouilles
des treize soldats américains tués dans
l'attentât du 26 août joe biden vivement
critiqué par les républicains pour sa
gestion de la crise afghane
l'une des pires décisions de politique
étrangère de l'histoire américaine selon
l'influent chef des sénateurs
républicains mitch mcconnell
washington qui réunit ce lundi en
visioconférence et partenaires clés afin
de discuter d'une approche aligné pour
la suite des opérations
alors que l'onu tiendra une réunion des
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité
est la france et le royaume uni à plaide
en faveur d'une zone protégée dans
kaboul paria et londres qu'ils doivent
présenter à l'onu à un projet de révolue
en ce sens une safe zone sous contrôle
onusien destinée à poursuivre les
opérations humanitaires selon emmanuel
macron à l'appel lancé hier à à
l'occasion de son déplacement en irak
lors d'un entretien accordé à nos
confrères de tf1 le chef de l'état qui a
évoqué des discussions inévitable avec
les talibans mais sous conditions on
l'écouté
c'est une solution qu'on connaît qu'on a
déjà vu se dessiner dans d'autres
théâtres d'opération
d'une d'une zone permettant de sécuriser
les arrivées à cet aéroport et la
protection des personnes je pense que ça
a un intérêt pourquoi d'abord parce que
ça mobilise toute la communauté
internationale ensuite parce que ça crée
une pression sur les talibans et parce
que mettons en actes ce qu'on leur
demande ils ont si vous voulez avancer
et avoir un pays ouvert au reste de la
région et du monde vous devez respecter
les règles humanitaires et permettre à
toutes les femmes et des hommes qui
veulent être protégés devant celles et
ceux plus tôt ce en espèces qui ont le
contrôle de kaboul et du territoire ce
sont les talibans et donc de manière
opérationnelle très pratique nous devons
avoir ces discussions
c'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire
quand je dis nous c'est la communauté
internationale cela ne préjuge pas d'une
reconnaissance
parce que nous avons posé des conditions
et de leur côté les talibans ont refusé
cette proposition de safe zone pas
nécessaire selon eux les insurgés qui
assure que chaque arguant sera bien
disposé à voyager à l'étranger si
ce n'est pas nécessaire l'afghanistan
est un pays indépendant
peut-on créer une telle zone en france
ou au royaume uni chaque afghan pourra
de toute façon après le 31 août voyagé à
l'étranger s'ils le souhaitent comme
c'est le cas dans n'importe quel pays où
il devra avoir les documents appropriés
passeports visas s'il dispose de cela
chacun pourra quitter l'afghanistan et y
venir en provenance de notre pays